hey youtubers it's Charlie so I saw a
lot of you guys still had questions
about John snows ability to work so this
video is just meant to be an explainer
for that I also found some stuff that
kid Harrington said personally so I
think that helps a little bit to just
careful for spoilers for everything
through episode 2 this season so just in
case it wasn't clear during the Q&A
video I did John snow in the books is a
warg I'm assuming on the TV show he will
also be one but he's still unconscious
of it he doesn't really understand it
the way brain understands it now
remember on the TV show Jojen had to
explain a lot of things to bran he had
to show him how to work now he's
learning about being a green seer which
is a completely separate thing so what a
lot of people are wondering is you know
did Jon Snow warg into ghosts when he
was dead so like during that period when
his body was dead was his mind inside
ghost the way kid Harrington explained
what the new Jon Snow is going to be
like the Risen Jon Snow is that he's
going to be seizing the opportunities
that life gives him he's not gonna be
holding back as much because he doesn't
want to go back to the empty void that
he felt when he was dead of course
they're gonna dress it on the TV show in
some way but he made it sound like when
he's explaining what he felt when he was
dead to Melisandre he just says I felt
nothing
there was nothing Ness he's being Jones
beats the other side no no no he's come
back he's he's seen something that very
very few people in this world have and
what he's seen is nothing he's in
Oblivion and that's got to change
someone in the most fundamental way
there is so I think we can assume based
on that the TV show Jon Snow did not
warg into ghosts when he died so
hopefully that answers that question
but that doesn't automatically mean that
that didn't happen for book Jon Snow so
that's still wide open for theory
crafting for another month or two or
however long it takes george RR martin
to finish winds of winter they still
don't have an official release date for
that yet
the funny thing or maybe they're not so
funny thing that a lot of people are
wondering now is did Dan and Dave hold
back the Jon Snow reveal til season six
because they wanted to give George R
Martin time to reveal it in the books
like originally I think the idea was to
release wins a winner before season six
came out it would give a big sales boost
to be this big marketing push but
because the disease
was made so long ago they shot film
those scenes aired episode 10 and that
was the point of no return so they just
had to commit to the Jon Snow being dead
lie but for those of you that really do
want to see Jon Snow warg in the future
it's still totally possible I mean
there's two more seasons and we have a
bunch more episodes this season too I
don't know that we'll see it this season
I think pending Melisandre pouring more
azor Ahai kool-aid down his throat or
trying to pour him the big supernatural
magical surprise for Jon Snow has
already happened I guess you could kind
of consider R + L equals J Tower of joy
flashback a bit of a Jon Snow
supernatural reveal because the way that
it happens in the way it ties into the
prophecy of the prince who was promised
there's all kinds of prophecies once it
absolutely confirms or denies theories
we can talk a little bit more about that
because the prince who was promised is a
really important theory for Rhaegar
Targaryen character but a lot of that
will depend on layout of stark stuff R +
L equals J so I'll try to mention that
depending on what happens during episode
3 I definitely expect to get an R + L
equals J moment in episode 3 but let me
know in the comments if George R Martin
has already confirmed that all the star
children are wargs do you think that we
will actually see Jon Snow warg on the
show consciously at some point do you
think will happen this season next
season do you think we'll never see it
for now I think the unspoken bond that
he shares with ghost will just be the
extent of their relationship it'll just
continue in that way they definitely
understand each other Han Solo Chewie
style the same way Daenerys and her
dragons understand each other that's
actually the next big thing - you've
seen the way ghost and Jon Snow share
their relationship I think learning more
about dragon bonding is gonna be a
really exciting thing this season they
might only address it in passing
Tyrion definitely seems like he's gonna
be studying dragons more and more this
season he's just completely fascinated
with them when I was little I asked my
uncle for a baby dragon and they all
laughed at me but here you are and I'm
kind of waiting to see whether or not
the show confirms or denies it but even
if Tyrion is not a Targaryen which I
don't think that he is I think it's
still possible that he could ride one of
the Dragons so when they say the dragon
has three heads he could still be part
of that on a TV show without actually
being a Targaryen but just because the
TV show does something doesn't
automatically mean that the books are
going to do it
because remember George R Martin is the
source for all this so even if there's a
big theory that doesn't pan out on the
TV show does not mean that it won't
happen in the books well what's gonna
happen this Sunday for my bonus video I
think just because they're gonna be
doing Tara joy I'll do a Lyanna stark
refresher I'll explain
terney of Harrenhal even that Rhaegar
Targaryen himself was a good person in
trying to get rid of the Mad King
because by that time he was pretty much
as crazy as he was when Jamie had to run
him through to keep him from burning the
city alive even if the show changes a
few minor things from the books there's
been some dialog changes it is getting
really exciting because now we can start
talking about some really big book
theories so through the rest of the
season I'll try to address all the
really big theories be sure to subscribe
to get it
I'll also be doing a new round of the
giveaway whenever I post that while you
guys wait for me to post that next video
you can click here for my episode 2
video from this week and you can click
here for last week's episode one video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you